nous sommes réunis en ce jour pour dire
au revoir au Chat Potté
tu es rendu à ta dernière vie
c'est l'heure de la retraite
[Musique]
voici votre nouveau colocataire
[Applaudissements]
il est là ton petit coin
[Musique]
je suis rendu à maternité
il était une fois un peu unique
attendant d'être exaucé qui dépasse
en fait
ok face de toi je ne vais pas me faire
prier
je sais très bien ce que je fais
quoi pourquoi il rigole il y a pas de
quoi rigoler
tout le monde recherche l'étoile aveu je
vais faire le vœu que tout soit juste
parfait
ta récompense ne va pas être simple à
gagner le Chat Potté bouclette les ours
[Musique]
sur le jardin
je ne suis plus rien quand tu n'as
qu'une vie à vivre c'est ce qui la rend
unique
pousse pas le bouchon
je vais m'amuser
[Musique]
l'étoile aveu se trouve dans la forêt
sombre on y va tous en même temps